les amis bienvenue dans des épisodes de
the last guardian souvenez vous à la fin
des épisodes précédents tricot a fait
une terrible chute après son combat
contre l'autre tricot cie coveney de
vomir le miroir qui va nous permettre
sûrement d'accéder à un endroit où
choper de la bouffe pour le remettre en
état de marche parce qu'il est vraiment
pas bien quoi à mon avis un truc à
regarder bah voilà cette fameuse chaîne
[ __ ] alors il faut qu'on dirige sa
tout là haut est ce que tricot à la
force ouais d'utiliser son pouvoir
nice c'est bien mon tricot allez courage
mon grand j'arrive j'espère qu'il y aura
au moins quatre barils mon verre
colliers offre un festin ouais avoir
détruit dans les décombres alors oui
[ __ ] on n'a jamais aussi content de
retrouver au plat parfait j'ai réussi à
lui tout dans la bouche
ça va te mettre bien aller le petit
deuxième hop là le deuxième parfait
moment
alors est ce que tu vas te lever où il
faut que j'aille chercher d'autres ça va
suffire
oui il a pas l'air de réagir je pense
qu'il y en faut plus tôt n'y a pas
trente-six chemins il ya là bas aussi
j'ai un peu plus qu'elle a dès qu'on va
aller voir s'il ya plus de bouffe même
temps là il a pris tellement cher que
wade doit il va lui falloir au moins
trop quatre tonneaux pour aller mieux
clore ce week-end je suis en train de
merde au document est maintenant âgé
vide autre tonneau amincie je me suis
évanoui ouais
le temps s'est un peu écroulé on est
tous les deux mal [ __ ]
abobo au crâne à les tricots ja on peut
entendre son coeur battre en plus c'est
horrible on voit qu'il est vraiment mal
quoi alors attends j'ai vu des tonneaux
là dedans
normalement à chjama regarde y en a un
là haut au plat un de plus et le petit
dernier je te ramène tout de suite ils
jetèrent toi hop là on est bon ça fait 4
est-ce qu'il faut encore j'ai recherché
ça va suffire
on est avec eux c'est la fin c'est début
de la nuit enfin la journée
tommy soutenu toni kroos tout au oui ok
une nouvelle journée peut-être la
dernière
c'est triste un ses marins avance l
inverse est ainsi chaque erreur contre
toi
yes
la forme
tu as tout donné
tard ils attaquent au jeu
allez on va monter est inquiète pas j'ai
compris on va tous montés mais oui il le
pense carrément là à pozo fait plaisir
rien et les grandes cornes qui leur
étaient adultes maintenant très quoi
t'es plus le bébé qu'on a est rouvert tu
perds pas de temps et elle va direct yes
oh [ __ ] c'est le prix que je pense
qu'il faut sortir le miroir des idées
pour ce tricot ça marche ou pas sur un
ennemi
ouais pas qu'un peu on va monter tout ça
mon gars on va ré atteindre le spes de
bâtiments bizarre qu'on avait trouvé on
est parti n'ose eu très très bien passé
super - on à un grand grand chemin à
faire et en plus faut que je fasse gaffe
s'il ya des gardes à bien les démolir
voilà je m'en doutais tu vis bien
hu ok on remonte vraiment où le niveau
d'avant quoi c'est ouf
du coup avoir pété la porte qu'elle a je
suppose ok on est bon comme ça tu vas
pouvoir sauter là bas en fait à mon avis
c'est là bas qu'il faut qu'on aille
ok ok toi tu perds pas de temps tu vas
direct à gauche bavaisis je te suis je
te suis taha
[ __ ] or voilà dans ces endroits là
qu'on est déjà passée par là les verts
ale mon grand tu peux le faire vas-y
vas-y les saisies et il a eu ce procès
où aller yes est ce que tu vas résister
aux ondes
on va le faire
safer tricot allez mon grand courage ça
va ça va resté bien on peut le cas si tu
penses tiko ça il m'a dit tu vas le pt
bravo mon grand et a résisté [ __ ] tu
bats ta peur des miroirs ensuite tu
pètes le truc qui envoie des ondes
allez on va pourrir les mecs on va
pouvoir foncé du coup je propose que
l'on tente de péter les miroirs de loi
oui hausse et pousse à plat entraîneur
star wars c'est magnifique
et voilà fin prêt à s'envoler tricot
j'espère confiant sur le saut je suis
pas au fond allait elle saute mon gars
là c'est bien ce que je fais mais il
faut que tu sautes vas-y soit tu
continues ou telle capacité
mais tu les exploite pas on a beaucoup
entendu cette phrase troublant il
trouvera ce que tu veux calculs et on y
va
yes parfait ça alors oui fallait qu'il
fasse du pilier pilier pour piliers
ouais c'est ça il assure le pilier voilà
et là on va tous traversé à l'aide des
piliers voilà parfait mon grand
ouais très très bien ouais on est dedans
splendide bon amant des braves en avion
n'a pas pété ici six en miroir pour soi
pas le chemin à prendre donc tricot tu
vas venir là et on va se baser sur celui
là comme une échelle finalement signé
une échelle pour les gens comme tricot 1
pour les monstres qui font 40 mètres
très très bien et comprend tout seul je
laime à elle a ensuite à vue c'est à moi
tout seul de faire ouais alors bougez
pas je vais devoir y aller mon tricot
je sais que tu es triste comme à chaque
fois que je dois tu es tout seul mais on
va très vite se retrouver comme à chaque
fois que je continue tout seul
il ya ça mais nous ça met une passerelle
en bois le long du bâtiment ok oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] j'ai failli me revoir et
normand je peux l'atteindre celui-là on
est d'accord il pas trop haut
ouais c'est juste moi qui me suis fait
chier dessus juste avant quoi hockey
rien n'est trop haut pour ce petit
garçon toute manière mais c'est vrai
donc la tricoteuse attendant journée si
je pars trop comment je vais pouvoir te
faire venait à retrouver la grille très
bien aller ramène toi on va devoir
traverser le pont la grâce à tes styles
de maître qui saute très très loin ouais
au nom au nom au nom au nom assez bon au
ses missions
vas-y à faut que je t'aide mains c'est
bon tu as réussi bien je mon tricot
tu as vu tête a grandi maintenant tu
sais elle est tout et tu tombes plus
quand le pont s'effondre
c'est donc tout s'effondre en plus dense
plus l'univers web pour accéder à
cette petite passerelle qui va nous
permettre de remonter via les trucs
comme celui là avec des torches allait
bien ok on est parti si yes ou là j'ai
un soin faire mon gars je vais compter
sur toi tricot alors c'est bon tu peux
danser
j'avais sauté m'accrocher à l'accord
bourgat la mort trop comme ça ce plan
des tricots à ya des gardes au québec
dont c'était extermine mon gars moi à il
arrive pas on est moins deux très bien
qu est au
merde aux obeaux ça va [ __ ] on est en
train de remonter vénère je suis sûr
qu'à la fin il va s'envoler et
s'accrocher à l'atout principal c'est
sûr ok j'ai pas eu qu'à me gonfle été
retirée juste après premier ok on est
bien il va falloir refaire un système
avec de l'élan je suppose à mesa moi
c'est les grilles de jeu peu passé entre
les barreaux mais me regarde pas comme
ça mon camp je vais faire ce qu'il faut
et à une petite marche ça va sûrement
être pour te taper c'est le pompier en
face
ok on est en haut escape à un système
pour abba voilà ça ça va être pour
activer le cran pour d'en face
alors voilà non celui de cette tour là
mais bon gratuite envers ses pattes sur
le mur à l'hérésie let's go contre
hyères faire le saut c'est parti ok on
lui a demandé s'il pouvait voler mais je
suis pas sûr qu'il puisse mentir je
prends les petites marches que ya là
elles ne sont clairement pas là pour
rien ok
ayez un levier
en fait c'est bête c'est de la bombe
bien ça juste le bessat juste qu'on fait
quelques coups en fait à ok c'est pour
prendre suffisamment d'élan pouvoir
s'envoler jusqu'à tour principal howe
quand on est lent
[Musique]
tous démoli nantis qu on va essayer
d'aller dans la tour mon gars c'est en
faisant le grand tour par là vous êtes
que l'espèce d'objets qu'on avait trouvé
la lafa connecter sur ce bâtiment lui
une espèce de jeu c'est pas enterré
quelque chose dans lequel faut mettre un
objet peut-être qu'il faut juste envoyé
le le qatar ont fait de miroirs dessus
en fait tomber une foire de tricot là
dedans on va voir ducasse était derrière
et bien tricot regarde ça jeu sur wii
c'est comme ça qu'on va accéder faut
mettre les miroirs simplement
ah bah voilà
moi
ça y est ça y est on rentre là dedans on
va avoir des réponses à nos questions
c'est fou mec qu'est ce qui se passe là
dedans tu fais mon grand qu'est ce
qu'ils foutent ici alors c'est beau
encore un truc dans lequel m les miroirs
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
spécial as et un ascenseur aa
oh c'est tellement eu merde au togo
audio de newton longueur du cou a dit hé
je peux pas te prendre michael a ok
c'est à moi de prendre trek
on y va oui je suis sûr que c'est par la
barrière de nickel ça va aller tricot on
a déjà vécu cette situation 600 mille
fois toi et moi et en plus tu actuel
pendant que je veux voir comment servir
pour démolir les gardes qui vont se
présenter à moi
alors elle regarde y'a des casques lasse
pas compliqué tu prends les castes eu
les fous dans l'armure et tu rejoins
tricot pour qu'ils aient des fonds c'est
avec ça que d'ailleurs hop
vas-y bien ok j'ai juste à sauter les
armures savent pas sauter et ensuite je
prends le miroir et je ferais tout mon
pote
ils fument alors allez c'est bon ça aux
îles après à bout portant beau gars
allez venez tous comme ça on n'en parle
plus ok on aura deux fois je mate les
casques
voilà qui est mieux rip mon ami voilà le
dernier a bien plongé sa grosse trace on
va pouvoir voir ce qui reste à faire là
avec les avec les slot de miroir est ce
que tous les slots ya vraiment une chose
à faux les activer en fait ok on va
continuer comme ça jusqu'à avoir tous
active et j'entends les pas d'un garde
ça me stresse à ces derniers je crois
celui-là ouais ça s'ouvre on arrive
tricot
quoi ça va nous mener tout en haut
ok go j'arrive n'y va pas sans moi ok on
est bon direction la vérité ces
particules d'un oh là là là ça va être
fou
on va monter super aux voix
allez mon tricot on va connaître
l'origine de notre existence
de tourner existant sur tout
[ __ ]
dans une nouvelle salle je me méfie il
ya plein de portes garde ça sent pas bon
du tout
ouah et voilà et voilà et voila voila
c'était sûr non secoue les avis c'est
lui qui a fini dans la porte le coup toi
tu vas arrêter avec une [ __ ] miroir
dialoguera voilà dans le trou aller au
bal plutôt miroir être correia toi là tu
es démontrer objet de couvrir mon grand
parce que ils veulent vraiment de choper
ça va je suis fort à l'épervier je mets
des belles formes et aux îles et à toute
volée même mois mais cela allait leur s
quelques-uns et aux textures qui a
toujours pas réussi à récupérer et son
drôle des fois on l'a vu elle jeta
retire les pieux on avance mon grand on
les arrête mon gars mais bon à malhao
mais qu il ya un signe de miroir tout là
haut
ouah bon ok oh non c'est un piège
non au oui haut la main le malin
amertume empêche d'y aller c'est pas
maintenant c'est bon vas-y vas-y vas-y
viège le tricot aux têtes fait trop mal
oh là là où est ce qu'on est en train
d'aller là hein
à temps mais ça monte pendant super
content il ya un truc à faire ce pas
possible
moi je peux vous dire que l'on n'ose
sommet se mettre là toi
qu'est-ce que ça ok j'ai déjà repéré un
truc qui brille là bas c'est de la
bouffe parfait voilà
ah ça c'est que d'étourneaux de bouffe
déchiqueté qui ont donc été mangé par
quelqu'un et c'est patrick au but le
tricot est jamais venu ici il ya du
bruit qui vient de hockey puisque
enelistes d'accord on n'est pas encore
sauvés sommeil on va devoir monter
tricot salariales de branche en branche
tu tiens là dessus toi mais oui on
regarde si nice mon grand hockey nice
excellent tu continues à monter
yes fais gaffe parce que bientôt on aura
la palme là qui va nous emmerder attend
c'est quoi c'est un petit tout pour moi
ça ok tricot je vais aller voir ce cas
là dedans ouais c'est ça c'est pour moi
l'un qui est inquiète inquiète j'arrive
je vais parce que hier
[Musique]
moi je suis à l'intérieur
la doudoune sommes où nous y eut
l'audace accroche tout ouïe et 6 à 6
le maître de la vallée
d'accord et je dois le ptc ça
où il importe quel camp je fais ça qu il
aime pas du tout en quelle année pour
stop and go falloir monter vite
ok up
ah [ __ ]
ok on est bon
ah merde
hop on est bon
on va pouvoir s'accrocher au dernier
truc si vous saviez comme j'ai galéré
atteindre ce stade monga aux saveurs
minutes au moins je cherche allez on
monte on va se retrouver à l'extérieur
et ça c'est les formes du cou qui
rendent foutry comme celle qui envoie
des ondes
c'est cette matière là à temps je me
tourne
on va y aller
ok
il faut sauter
il faut sauter sur ce truc là qui va
super vite mais non
ouah ok on est dessus au donc là il va
falloir qu'on aille à hawaii par contre
je galère à bouger alors qu'on allait y
avait un miroir n'est ce pas aller trop
trop vite il est là ok on met ça là
oh non
on a arrêté le truc tricot il va pouvoir
nous rejoindre c'est ça je crois qu'il a
le temps de sortir je vais le rejoindre
par là
taylor patricot
attends je vais sortir d'ici est ce que
tu es là j'aurai bientôt voir oui tu es
là mon grand ou des comptes à vous on
trouve à thé toujours content quand on
se retrouve
mais qu on est au sommet de la tour
qu'est ce qu'on fait tricot la
thématique
il envoyait un signal pour attirer des
tricots
c'est quoi ce bordel
waaa les ondes over puissante voix
à
oh
[ __ ]
vous n'êtes pas
à ces lots il ramène les enfants
et en échange le truc d'envoi de la
bouffe
[Musique]
tapez pas très bien
12 à vouloir me bouffer pour avoir de la
bouffe
morales a mâché droit
[Musique]
miroir miroir du miroir pour je trouve
le miroir mais je sais pas jusqu'où il a
roulé à la baille bridge le bois ok
hop
à
vous
qui aimerait même
le miroir il est là bas je le vois
waouh
ok le miroir
ok je lai
high value déchets
non
ok je vais arriver là que de tri qu elle
l est a dû tomber dans le coeur je vais
l'activent avec les miroirs et ça va
tout faire péter
non non
[Musique]
laissez moi un modèle il faut que j'ai
chopé la queue du coup enfin je vais la
mettre à côté du coeur de du maître de
la vallée là mon cul et je pense que ça
va le savent à le démolir sa maman y'a
pas la place pour qui un tricot puisse
aller là bas j'ai vu qu'ils lui ont
arraché la queue [ __ ] dit qu il en
train de se faire dévorer vivants ces
eaux vives
elle vient faites-moi la queue de tricot
tiens on tombe tous les deux ok on va
mettre tellement cher à ce [ __ ] de
kurt ya saloperie
alors on espère que la coquetterie qu
elle te tire dessus
ça va faire mal
hu allait encore encore
[Musique]
vous serez
tous
[Musique]
comme tricot quand il s'est pris un coup
d'éclat
à
[Musique]
il
tant va l'emporter
les banques est en deuil
[Musique]
moi je tricot
on
les gens
[Musique]
mais
au monsieur tueur
[Musique]
et cela
partout
[Musique]
atik et on nous a donné tout
je
[Musique]
pour la diagne coucou dieu et du tram à
son bas ou la tunisie
angotti à duke ou à dessiner car guy à
aa
saloperie de jeu et bas est ce que c'est
pas la fin qu'on imaginait tous en fait
qu'ils soient séparés au président
thomas sap revend de ma vie que je
et ben voilà les avis c'est la fin de ce
net se plaît à a
c'était une [ __ ] de belles histoires
on a vu du coût qui était le grand
méchant on a vu qu'il y avait un
milliard de tricot qu'ils étaient tous
sous l'emprise de ce grand méchant qu'on
a réussi à détruire jusqu'au bout tricot
il aura été fidèle et mignon des larmes
coulent sur son visage pour une fois
c'est pas de l'oat les amis j'étais
tellement à fond dans ce jeu j'étais
j'ai tellement envie d'y jouer tout le
temps devant la fin de l'histoire que
[ __ ] pts pas comme un film là c'est
quand même tu passes 11 12 heures tu
vois beaucoup plus de péripéties entre
les deux persos que dans un film enfin
d'un film ça dure une heure et demie la
[ __ ] c c'est vachement long plus de
chaldée moment émotion là avec une
musique triste [ __ ] là j'espère
secrètement à une petite scène de fin
d'après- générique on voit tricot qui je
sais pas qui vient déposer un atout
notre bouffe au pied du du village un
sérieux pour montrer qu'il a envie quoi
c'est la fin de générique ça se termine
sur le miroir
est-ce qu'on a une scène de fin s'il
vous plaît ça des zooms
oh
henry
oui
who were m
[Musique]
non
c
[Musique]
voilà ce qu'on appelle un chef-d'oeuvre
tout simplement ben voilà les amis c'est
la fin de cette vidéo et ce let's play
c'était super bass à tous d'avoir suivi
je m'attendais pas ce que vous soyez
aussi nombreux à le suivre vu que c'est
un jeu assez lent à ses fins voilà c'est
de la poésie c'est sarah voir avec les
jeux d'horreur où ça bouge tout le temps
et c'est là c'est vraiment lent posée
mais mais c'était une très belle
histoire je vous remercie encore une
fois et puis je vous dis à très dans une
prochaine vidéo forte des mots viaggio
propice